hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Arianna
ba Suri today we're checking out a video
called if characters said what they're
actors tweeted I believe this video is
my college humor they're funny they have
a good sense of humor
hence college human it's kind of like
college related joke yeah yeah I know it
called Schumer's gotcha
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I had a xxx ink you want the truth you
can't handle the truth
Wow there are a lot of people with the
name Bieber in their name
wait what we should figure out how to
turn justin bieber names into energy
what does that have to do with anything
[Music]
I love you did you ever notice every
other planet has a cool name exists with
earth depressing let's talk about
something important I love that song
[ __ ] in Paris Kanye and I should do a
song called [ __ ] in Montauk anyone who
isn't floating the title of that song is
racist is a disgrace to the human race
I'm sorry that is incorrect
the phrase is global warming alarmists
are unpatriotic racists knowingly
misleading for their own ends dangerous
mission yet there's no shame in backing
out if anyone wants to say anything now
is the time love is the most powerful
and still most unknown energy in the
world hey guys what's your spiritual
outlet these days I'm curious I am a
lesbian I love every piece of you feed
me I'm always hungry I'm yours forever
that one makes sense I'm kind of
surprised by some of these actresses I
am shocked I had no idea most these
people even tweeted and they say
ridiculous things Russell Crowe for
example you would not expect him to out
of all like actors yeah he's such a
serious Tom Cruise tweets what the hell
I love Tom Cruise and I know he tweets a
lot of people get mad at me when I say
that there aren't a lot of people with
the name Bieber in their name yeah I
don't know what Tom Cruise I'm sorry
specific thing to accuse maybe Tom
Cruise had a sarcastic sense of humor
Tom Cruise tweet huh I want to follow
I'm gonna follow Tom Cruise it's pretty
funny follow Tom Cruise I want to follow
Tom Cruise into his bubble last thing
you're gonna say is something about his
ass I have a very few like racial jokes
just a small dick push back yeah
porn topic yeah they're all just sex
related and that's about as far as - I
have a square box of humor and that's
what goes in that box I know it's the
lone tweens
it's my Stallone impression the third
tooth day is like Down syndrome or
something haha and that box there's also
Down syndrome jokes get ready for more
of those I hope no your relatives have
it but if they do they are funny Alec
Baldwin I know is a crazy tweeter Alec
Baldwin is awesome he's one of those
funny actors he's really talented but
he's got a crazy personal my dad an Alec
friendly more than one time together he
gave him some jellybeans it's like a box
of jelly beans oh you got your dad's dry
clean steamer cleaners people great
place to go if you want to get your
laundry done dry cleaning
my cane yeah and they have popcorn there
popcorn candy this isn't that I'm sure
your father is really proud of you I
don't know I'm slightly under the
weather our beginning a little bit
better that's why there hasn't been as
many videos lately but I don't tell
guests that because they wouldn't come
over if I said I was like sick you know
where the [ __ ] are you going get your
ass back home sorry Jesus Arianna well
you don't believe in Jesus you're Jewish
but I really got from this video was
there's a lot of celebrities who try to
be deep over Twitter right well a lot of
them you have to remember are artists
actors yeah I mean I miss you guys she
just wants to know your spiritual outlet
what do you think hers is probably no
yeah there you go that's her religion
right there well anyway guys thanks for
tuning in to the real rejects if you're
new to the Chanel you can subscribe to
the real region and you can check out
ariana Bathory's channel the Ariana
Basara channel as it's called and you
can follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter where if we get enough followers
we can get product placements but
instead of doing I don't know normally I
whip out a product it takes something
from somewhere yeah but today I'm gonna
do a shout out
Jamie tea merit you guys are [ __ ]
awesome
I watch all your videos the what about
m'kay fatalities was so funny hoped to
collab together
god bless bro James T Merritt wants to
collab meaning he has a channel meaning
I'm gonna show your face to people
though he's black he's blind he's a
black well I know I just think that I
haven't collabed with a black person yet
and it's very intentional I'm very
particular about the blacks I hang up
I'm kidding
Tyrone Magnus and I are friends and he's
black Ariana likes black [ __ ] a lot
right no too big for you there hurt
what's it like it's feel good yeah okay
James T merit tonight you can jerk off
the Ariana I believe in respecting your
image really respecting respecting you
as a woman and I want James C Merritt to
touch himself to you so that way he
understands how beautiful of a woman you
are take care of your dick